they've found a place to live now after
fleeing afghanistan with little more
than the clothes on their backs
the ala mazata family has only a few
months to figure out how to pay for it
i'm going to start everything from zero
rama tula
worked as an interpreter back home
but has resigned himself to physical
labor here in his new home in the state
of new jersey
he's got some job offers but will need
to buy a car to be able to get to work
first
the other cast the other bill is so high
i must work hard to pay all them
it is very difficult for me
hey are you by any chance at the
warehouse the reformed church of
highland park is helping and we will
soon be hiring a refugee school impact
coordinator pastor seth caperdale has
been resettling refugees for years and
says donations have been pouring in so
all this stuff is going to afghan
families who are resettling all around
central new jersey everything from
mattresses to money since some 80 000
afghans were airlifted to the united
states
we were deeply concerned then kabul fell
in august and as we watched the same
horrific scenes that everybody else did
of the chaos at the airport we knew that
um
quite soon we'd be experiencing a surge
like we'd never experienced in terms of
arrivals
they found the alamozada family and more
than 200 other afghans a place to live
nearly triple their annual numbers in a
part of the country where affordable
housing is hard to come by
in a matter of six months the united
states resettled all but seven thousand
afghans evacuated as part of operation
allies welcome into communities across
the country but those seven thousand
remain on two military bases one in
wisconsin and one here in new jersey
but some families tired of waiting for
replacement have begun leaving on their
own according to the hebrew immigrant
aid society
haius is one of the nine resettlement
agencies tasked with overseeing
community placements capacity-wise we
were not ready
funding-wise we were not ready that we
will be able to support you know the
influx of afghan arrivals
that's a concern for refugees most of
whom have at this point only been given
temporary visas
we are here right now we don't know what
is our future
they are thankful to those who have
helped them land here
but relief has been replaced by worry
kristin salumi al jazeera spotswood new
jersey